we're in California because it's the
pulse of skateboarding and it's ironic
that while we're the state that applauds
innovative technologies we have a law in
the books that prohibits the
electrically motorized industry from
growing skateboarding is not a crime or
at least it shouldn't be but in
California at the center of tech
innovation not to mention home two
wonders like Lords of Dogtown and green
electric skateboarding is banned I think
the biggest issue with the legislation
right now is that it's pretty unclear it
kind of is a telling sign but the person
who wrote this bill is I think in their
80s now back in the 70s California
outlawed motorized skateboards because
they were heavy polluters in terms of
both emissions and noise but like most
of their technologies they've evolved so
let your skateboards are a really fun
and fast way to complete those in
between commutes since it's purely
electric we have zero tailpipe emissions
we use regenerative braking we use
highly efficient motors and batteries
which really allows us to go a long way
on a charge Ben Foreman is the
co-founder of intuitive motion an
electric skateboard manufacturer based
in Northern California he launched his
product Z board with a Kickstarter
campaign back in 2012 and his product
has since been in high demand we've
built thousands of boards ship them to
all 50 states over 45 countries so the
reception has really been amazing there
are certain people that aren't going to
want to buy into this market until this
gray area the legislation is cleared up
this is just one example of California's
excessive regulatory environment state
Assemblymember Christian Olson is
working with Foreman to craft
legislation that lifts the ban I've been
carrying a bill assembly bill 20 54 that
would legalize the use of electrically
motorized skateboards in transportation
corridors across California we want to
make sure that California remains the
center of innovation the real reason
that we're pursuing this is because it's
potentially putting a ceiling on our
market a ceiling on our business a
ceiling on how many boards we can build
a ceiling on how many
square-feet that we can rant how many
people we can hire I've learned that
very few things are easy in the
legislative process especially when it
involves change and new technologies and
so a lot of the challenge with being
able to move a bill like this through
the legislature is dispelling the myths
that are in people's minds that really
have nothing to do with what this board
is about just ask fella foremen who took
valuable time away from his five-man
business operation to trek up to
Sacramento and educate lawmakers so we
had an electric skateboard demonstration
in a Plaza outside the capital last year
my partner went around different offices
at the Capitol to get people
demonstrations of the product informant
says reviews were positive their
proposed legislation didn't meet any
serious opposition aside from some
cyclists who expressed concern about
having to share the road electric
skateboarding in a lot of ways it isn't
a partisan issue
it's clean it's creating jobs but even
without any political opposition EB 2054
has had to go back to the drafting stage
because as Foreman found out the
legislative process is extremely
convoluted if it had been me personally
all by myself trying to figure out the
future this legislation I would have had
no clue where to start we discovered as
we were working on 80/20 54 in the
legislative process that there are a lot
of technical challenges that need to be
fixed to make sure that it's consistent
with other parts of the vehicle code and
the language is being written concisely
enough Olsen plans to reintroduce the
bill early next year and despite the
snail's pace of the political process
they are still optimistic about reform
so it's been an uphill battle the fact
that it's taking a little bit longer
than we would have liked initially has
been a bit of a headache we've made a
lot of progress we believe at the end of
the day we will be able to pass 80/20 54
and we will see the prohibition against
these motorized skateboards deleted from
law